or so i love video games you might like
video games but i really love the
history of video games so i found myself
a really sweet
video game documentary on netflix and
we're going to talk about that so high
score is a video game documentary on
netflix and it takes you through the
history of video games it's not a beat
by beat kind of thing
every episode really concentrates on
some technological
leap forward you know that moment when
video games took a leap
and they just wouldn't be the same after
that until gamer nostalgia said hey
let's let's go back
for some nostalgic games but you know
leap forwards nonetheless and it's not
just home console gaming when he talks
about arcades and how really
like pac-man had a pattern right my dad
used to tell me that my dad knew the
pac-man pattern and then he was like
one day it was different well this talks
about how it became different
because arcades were like dude we're
losing money people can put one quarter
and last hours on these things and so
these guys made these little circuit
boards that arcade owners could open up
the arcade machines and put in there and
it changed up the patterns and they did
the same thing for missile command and
then atari was like nah we're going to
sue you for [ __ ] with our machines
which is funny because
one could argue it brings in more
revenue but then if i'm jumping around
you fast forward a couple episodes later
and there's this guy who wants to see if
he can make 3d graphics on the game boy
nintendo was like that's impossible so
they fly him and his friend to japan
and miyamoto's like we want to do
graphics like that on the super nintendo
here's a contract want to work for us
and i love that such an amazing thing
also shows the difference in perspective
of business where it's like all right
sue these guys for doing something hire
these guys for doing something
different companies just see it
differently but because nintendo hired
these guys they made the fx chip which
gave us star fox and there you go
and that's the thing i love about this
mini series documentary it really did
celebrate the creative spirit how it's
not just
these aren't isolated incidents the
entire history of video games is
it's one story with a lot of players
all feeding off of each other getting to
the next stage the next level those are
yes those are puns whatever a video game
production and programming
i love that about this it's not so much
okay well we have this technology to
work with
now so now we can do the next thing it's
the creative spirit of these people who
wanted to break the boundaries of the
technology at the time when imagination
would just push video games to its
limits you know you had space invaders
and
essentially for a while video games were
just
things from space that were falling from
space and you shot them until someone
was like i really like those text based
games and then her husband was like
let's put graphics to it and there you
are now you're role playing you're
playing dungeons and dragons essentially
but in a video game
you're no longer just shooting things
from space you're playing a story
and yes it talks about the video game
crash of atari you know
people were like we're not interested
anymore it does make a strong argument
that maybe
that et game was a part of it but you
see the developer's side and he was like
yeah
i made this et game here's how it went
down
from my perspective for every hated game
there's someone who just
wanted to do right by the world or at
the very least bit off
a bit more than they could chew my
favorite thing was when i got to the
point where i was like oh i remember
this
like i remember the great console war
super nintendo sega genesis
and i had heard a lot of the story
before but one of the funniest things
was this
guy was like oh yeah we basically had a
sega plant
in every college campus in america and
we just gave that kid free
sega [ __ ] dude i mean
this is pretty brilliant i mean all's
fair in love and war and super nintendo
vs sega genesis
that was a war my friends what makes it
so fundamentally different from today's
wars well
you could still be friends with people
on the other side i guess
we had a different mindset back then you
see interviews from former game
counselors which was that was just the
job that i wanted that's what i wanted
to do
i mean i've done well for myself in the
world so i have no complaints at all and
i
count myself among the blessed but man
elementary school the high school is
like i just want to be a game counselor
i just want to be a game tester
i just want to play video games for a
living my mom my mom was always very
encouraging to me and like anything i
wanted to do
she was she was one of those encouraging
moms i was like oh you want to do that
thing you should do that thing she told
me like you should
take an ad out in the paper and be like
hey call this number and
i'll tell you how to get past levels and
video games i just remember being like
that just sounds daunting and if i can't
answer a question it's gonna be so
embarrassing so i didn't do it but she
gave me that shot
thanks mom i remember that but in the
sega genesis super nintendo story
high score concentrates more on the
genesis side of things because we love
the underdog and genesis was
that i just like seeing that side of it
and funny thing
madden football was a big thing for
genesis they were like we really want to
bring sports into it and
ea electronic arts was like we want to
make a madden football game so they
worked together and they made that
and that was such a huge leap for
football games it was like the first
football game
in which players really felt like oh
yeah i'm actually playing a football
team
so what was once a technological
revolution for sports games
has become that yearly cash grab of ea
[ __ ]
kind of cracked me up i just found high
score to be a great
celebration of video game love because
if you're into video games if you're
into esports if you're into games today
it all came from this and it's not
unconnected it's not disconnected
it's all from the same it's all part of
the same symphonies what i'm trying to
say and that's the point that this
documentary high score drives home
these game developers may be separated
by years they may be separated by
decades but it's the love passion and
imagination of these game developers who
are just
pushing the technology breaking bounds
and they're all creating the same
symphony together they don't have to
know each other
they don't have to have met each other
they don't even have to know that each
other exists
there are a lot of unsung heroes in the
world of video games this not only shows
how it got there it shows that it was
just
passion from people before it was even
i mean video games were a joke for a
while yeah
marvel dc comic books video games this
was all stuff when i was in junior high
you get your ass kicked talking about
that stuff i got into some
arguments with some people about how
video game music
is art is it don't worry no friends of
mine
all my friends were always like yeah
yeah my brother yeah he's in my corner
we were all in each other's corner but
when high score was talking about how
game sound helps in the immersion and is
a very
necessary part of it i was like thank
you anyhow i love retro games i love
retro gaming i love
video game history and i really love
this documentary high score it's on
netflix check it out also
side note and kind of shout out youtube
channel gaming historian if you like
video game history
check out that channel i love that
dude's channel too his video
won the history of super mario bros 3.
check it out however we get to the
sponsorship segment of this video this
video is sponsored by postmates and in
the course of filming this video yes
the doorbell did ring and the food did
come and there it is
the sound of dogs going bananas the
sounds of gypsy and danger
they're the best alarms ever the foods
here actually came earlier than i
thought i'm gonna put this a little
later
in the video magic the magic of editing
postmates is a food delivery app
tons of local restaurants around you use
postmates to deliver food right to your
home you can do no contact delivery like
i just did so no problem there on the
postmates app you can watch the process
of delivery from pickup to delivery all
in real time there's a local
family-owned indian restaurant near me
that i love so yeah
chicken korma baby which is funny i
tried to get these
close-up beauty shots of the food i've
never seen a food
be so delicious and so not camera
friendly
as chicken korma it really is delicious
and if you enter the promo code you see
right here on screen five off john's you
get yourself five dollars off your first
two delivery orders of 15
or more side note 5 off john's my
nickname in high school not true but it
is the promo code
also the offer expires 10 days after
your first promo code redemption so
please keep that in mind so click the
link below get yourself postmates save
yourself some money with that promo code
and support your community support your
local family-owned restaurants on these
tough times and thank you once again to
postmates for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it alright so high score
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite
video game history youtube channel
youtube video give me more content
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]